not everything in this world is exactly
as it seems in fact there are many
creatures in the wild that go out of
their way to be deceptive to disguise
themselves as something entirely
different from their true nature
aggressive mimicry refers to a
phenomenon in which Predators or
parasites take on the appearance of
something harmless or even appealing in
order to lure in their intended prey or
host without detection they might
resemble food an inanimate part of the
environment or even a potential mate
whatever they choose they're secretly a
wolf in sheep's clothing in the deep
dark Waters of the ocean the anglerfish
dangles and alluring light from its head
ushering in little fish that it can trap
in its mouth and devour whole the
alligator snapping turtle Wiggles its
long tongue like a worm attracting
Hungry Fish looking for their next meal
instead they become the meal for
something bigger and more clever than
them false cleaner fish share their
appearance of another species one that
helps clean larger fish in a symbiotic
relationship when the imposters find a
victim they swim close under the
pretense of cleaning only to take a bite
out of them and swim away
Predators use similar illusions on land
too anti-mimicking jumping spiders wave
their false antenna in the air in an
imitation of an ant's movements
isolating the insects from their colony
before dragging them back to their Lair
to be devoured the mouth parts of the
male spiders are shaped like the head of
an ant but this imitation head splits
apart to reveal the spider's fangs and
its true intentions the photores Firefly
lights up its body in a mimicry of other
Firefly species mating signals signaling
male fireflies looking for companionship
when they respond to the call however
they will not find a willing mate
waiting but instead a femme fatale of a
firefly that just wants to eat the
spider-tailed horned viper has a bulbous
tip on its tail with false legs jutting
out on either side as the snake Wiggles
its tail running it across the ground
while the rest of its body lies in way
just out of sight a hungry bird spots it
from above when the bird swoops down to
seize the opportunity snake reveals
itself snapping up the unfortunate bird
before it can escape thankfully humans
are so much smarter and more observant
than fish ants and birds we're safe from
that sort of trickery there aren't any
animals out there who've learned how to
look like something familiar something
every day just to put unsuspecting
people at ease and lures into its
waiting Jaws right wrong only a couple
of years ago the SCP Foundation
discovered a being that has mastered
aggressive mimicry on a level previously
unseen in the natural world
unfortunately for us its prey of choice
happens to be humans and its hunting
ground is the very cities where we like
to think we're safe from something much
bigger meaner and hungrier than us a
short video went viral on a popular
social media platform the specific
platform has been redacted from official
files but the details of it are clear a
popular Creator on the app a young woman
known for her makeup tutorials and
restaurant recommendations around her
native city of Los Angeles she was live
streaming and answering questions while
going about her day when she stepped
onto a train at one of the Metro
stations around the city the train was
extremely crowded and she was preparing
to end the live video planning to resume
once she reached her destination but
just as she went to press the button at
the end of the stream something strange
happened the train went dark and the
space flooded with a strange thick
liquid the girl screamed to neither pain
horror or both and dropped the phone
whatever it fell into must have degraded
the phone at an extremely rapid Pace
because the video feed cut out
immediately after a splash all across
social media people shared the video
with one question in mind what happened
on that train fans mounted a campaign to
find the influencer to help her if she
was in any immediate danger but there
were no leads her friends and family
said she never came home that day and
when authorities attempted to trace her
phone they could not get any kind of
signal becoming increasingly concerned
about this missing girl and the
possibility of some kind of unreported
train accident authorities contacted the
Los Angeles metro and showed them the
video footage but every train was
accounted for and in pristine condition
there had been no strange chemical leaks
no crashes and certainly nothing like
what the video appeared to show at the
same time there were missing persons
reports being filed all across the
country in every area with a thriving
public transportation system not only
were the occupants of the Los Angeles
train unaccounted for with no wreckage
or bodies to be found but people were
disappearing in train stations in New
York Boston Chicago Washington DC and
more a woman reported her husband
missing after he called her to check in
during his daily commute home from work
the train had kept going for much longer
than it ordinarily did drifting off of
its usual route he told her that
something was wrong that he had a
terrible feeling of foreboding and then
the call cut off
he never made it home for dinner a young
woman was on her way to start an
internship at a prestigious New York
City magazine but never arrived for her
first meeting when her would-be boss
reached out to the girl's roommate all
he knew was that she had planned to take
the train to work that morning a private
detective trailing a man's wife for him
looking for evidence of an affair lost
track of her when she stepped onto a
train downtown he took the next train
hoping to catch her at what he assumed
would be her stop but she never got off
he wasn't able to track her down and had
to give her suspicious husband the news
that his wife had somehow vanished Into
Thin Air it wasn't just one or two
people every so often either entire
train cars of people were just
disappearing never to be seen again no
matter how hard anyone tried they could
not find any answers no logical
explanation for what could have happened
fortunately the video circulated so
widely that it made it onto the feed of
an SCP Foundation employee was idly
scrolling during a bathroom break he was
so shocked by what he saw that he almost
forgot to pull up his pants before
running out into the Hall fortunately he
did remember and rushed to his
supervisor's office fully clothed after
determining that the video was not a
hoax or some kind of viral marketing
stunt intended to sell a new brand of
spicy chips the SCP Foundation decided
to launch a formal investigation into
anomalous activity involving trains and
subway systems around the country task
forces were set up in every major city
and field researchers were assigned to
take the train all day every day as much
as possible as they did they would
maintain communication with the head of
their task force would monitor their
findings via hidden cameras and
microphones a week passed without
incident and the foundation was starting
to wonder if somehow the Los Angeles
video had been faked when the Chicago
task force made a harrowing Discovery
officer Jamie Bauer was assigned to
monitor the trains on Chicago's Blue
Line taking the train throughout the day
in keeping an eye on for suspicious or
potentially anomalous Activity one
weekend and he pretty much had it down
to a basic routine he would grab
breakfast hop on the train and enjoy his
coffee and meal while reading a book and
riding the train to its last stop then
he'd pick up lunch and do the same thing
all over again he'd have dinner and
repeat it wasn't too exciting but then
again excitement in this case probably
meant Horrors Beyond his comprehension
so he was perfectly fine with traversing
the city in a subway car and catching up
on the backlog of murder mysteries he'd
been meaning to read it was Monday
afternoon he'd picked up a slice of deep
dish pizza excited to try it for the
first time and walk down into the metro
station as he took his first bite can
you try not to chew into your microphone
please it's gross Dr Susan Shepard the
head of the Chicago task force spoke
into Jamie's earpiece you got it boss
you said this mouthful thanks see
anything unusual today she asked you
tell me you can see the video feed right
he took another bite chewing as quietly
as he could sure but you're on the
ground just keep an eye out okay be
careful remember to draw your weapon if
something goes south don't just
disappear into your book and forget to
keep your wits about you Dr Shepard's
side yep getting on the train now not
gonna talk much so these folks don't
think I'm nuts Jamie waited for the
doors to open and just for a moment
notice that they seem to stick just a
little this time nothing to be too
worried about though everything looked
normal just as it had on every other
ride he'd taken he could feel the Agatha
Christie book calling to him from inside
of his tote bag and he wanted to crack
it open and see what Clues haircut Roe
had come across but Dr Shepard was right
he'd been slacking off he needed to pay
attention to his surroundings so he did
just that he watched as the train car
steadily filled up with passengers
college students with bags full of books
and exhausted Expressions middle-aged
people in business attire tourists
wearing souvenir baseball caps and
snapping pictures of everything inside
before too long the train was completely
packed and Jaime could barely move
without bumping elbows with someone it
was a little claustrophobic but that was
public transportation Jamie leaned back
in his seat pulled his book out and
focused on the comforting Rumble of the
engine the Rhythm Of The Wheels On The
Tracks suddenly without warning the
train screeched to a stop they were in
the middle of a tunnel Jaime assumed
from the darkness that flanked them out
the window on either side wait was it
dark where the windows just disappeared
he squinted through the Blackness and
tried to see what was outside but he
couldn't make sense of his surroundings
all around the other passengers were
becoming Restless nervous some were
calling for help others were just
complaining doc you seeing this Jamie
hist into the microphone I don't see a
thing Dr Shepard replied are you all
right fine the trains just stalled I
don't know where or what's wrong with it
Jaime began feeling along the walls of
the train looking for doors
that's weird what well the crack in the
doors when they come together should be
right here but it's all smooth no gaps
or anything like it's all one thing and
it feels strange like he cut himself off
as his stomach dropped a sudden Rush of
fear of flooding his senses like what Dr
Shepard pressed like it's alive Jamie
said shakely Campbell what's happening
in there Dr Shepherd began taking
Furious notes on her hand I don't know
it's so dark everyone's scared I'm
scared I don't think this is a train I
don't know what it is but it's nothing
good as Jaime felt around he smelled
something sour foul and sharp in his
nose he heard liquid splashing onto the
ground the sound of something sizzling
and then people started to scream as he
felt along the wall something dripped
onto his hand and then it started to
burn he cried out in agony as whatever
had dripped onto him ate away at the
skin dissolving his hand bit by bit what
is it Dr Shepard's voice shook as she
heard the pain in Jaime's voice some
kind of acid oh God it's everywhere it's
on the walls floors it just keeps coming
he trailed off oh God oh God we're in
his stomach whatever this thing is it's
eating us Campbell you need to get out
of there right now Dr Shepard ordered
draw your weapon whatever you need to do
just get out Jamie pulled out his weapon
and started firing at the place where
the doors should be but the bullets
bounced off uselessly as if the fleshy
material was the side of a tank he fired
until there was no more ammunition left
and then he just kept squeezing the
trigger some more out of pure survival
Instinct but all it got him was a
useless click and the certainty that the
one thing he had brought with him in
case of emergency was completely useless
all the while the acid was creeping
higher dripping from every surface
filling a train car until it swallowed
the cries for help and the screams of
fear and Agony all Dr Shepard could do
was listen helpless as Jaime and the
rest of the passengers were digested
inside of the massive stomach what
happened to officer Jamie Campbell was
tragic but it provides provided
important information that the
foundation would likely never have
gotten otherwise they now knew a few key
things about this new anomaly it was
some kind of living thing able to
disguise itself as a train it was
resilient to bullets and firearms and it
was hiding in plain sight in order to
hunt human beings they had found the
culprit for the rash of mysterious
disappearances and it was a race of
unidentified creatures capable of taking
on the shape of a common underground
train the Newfound information quickly
circulated throughout the foundation
making its way to the various task
forces assigned to operation Metro as it
had been unofficially nicknamed task
force members were no longer instructed
to board trains instead they would slip
hidden cameras onto as many train cars
as they possibly could each outfitted
with a tracking device then the
foundation could remotely monitor the
trains for any potential signs of the
mysterious creatures looking for
imposters masquerading as trains without
unnecessarily losing anymore more
operatives in action now as for what
they would do once they found one of
these massive creatures was still
uncertain but at least they had
somewhere to Star the SCP Foundation
tried and failed to contain several
instances of the carnivorous species
before they finally got it right they
attempted to freeze the inside of one
train with liquid nitrogen hoping to
incapacitate the creature before it
could feed defend itself or Escape
custody the extreme cold seemed to have
no effect however and the false train
slammed its doors shot at the first sign
of discomfort then sped away at high
speed as it did the task force members
noticed that though they could hear the
sound of wheels on the tracks they could
see legs jutting out of the bottom of
the creature scuttling along the ground
next they attempted to take out the
creature's legs and render it immobile
so that it could be subdued the legs
were resilient to external damage
becoming hard as a rock whenever any
weapon blade or other Implement made
contact with them one Task Force member
trying to physically hold some of the
legs and place but they shifted their
shape becoming appendages resembling
tentacles and threw the man out of the
way before the false train hurried out
of the tunnel and out of sight they were
then able to track down a predatory
train just after a feeding when it was
slightly sluggish after a large meal
they pumped and aerosolized poison into
the Train's interior the belly of the
Beast potent enough to take out a
dinosaur and were relieved to find that
the creature was unable to flee
unfortunately though they were able to
subdue the creature they killed it in
the process at first they assumed it was
just inactive but it never resumed
activity again it was just like an
ordinary train car almost when the
interior was touched it felt warm and
slightly pliable less like metal and
plastic and more like flesh the longer
the creature was still the more the
windows on the sides stopped looking
like Windows and started looking like
wide glassy eyes the front of the train
became a gaping maw the silhouette of
the conductor inside reveal there's an
extension of the creature's body
resembling a tongue survivors and
Witnesses were given an amnestic to
remove any memories of the supposed
killer trains running under their city
and the foundation prepared to bring the
dead specimen in for further study a
cover story was used involving massive
repairs to the train system and while
the tunnels were closed off they managed
to remove the creature and transported
to a nearby Foundation containment site
there it was given one of the most
extensive autopsies in Foundation
history and the first one conducted
largely from inside the subject the
autopsy provided a more in-depth look at
the nature of the bizarre creature and
its curious nature the creature
nicknamed the trainee eater referring to
its preferred disguise and favorite
activity was one of an apparent species
of carnivorous predators that use
shape-shifting and an advanced form of
aggressive mimicry to prey on commuters
tourists and anyone else in need of a
ride from one place to the next it would
mimic the shape feel and sounds of a
train welcoming unassuming victims into
its stomach and once it was completely
full and able to efficiently feed it
would release an incredibly potent
stomach acid into the compartment and
quickly dissolve everything inside the
creature was highly adaptable able to
harden parts of its body at will and
display extreme resilience to weapons of
any kind due to this nearly impenetrable
flesh victims trapped inside would be
unable to force their way out as the
research staff turned in their autopsy
results and official report there was a
sense of unease in the air as everyone
wondered how many of these things are
out there which innocent trip to work
might be their last and how on Earth
could they hope to contain something
that could exist in endless numbers
something so expert at hiding in plain
sight there was no realistic way to
bring all these creatures into custody
and so they would have to neutralize as
many as possible without being detected
Foundation operatives embedded in
various city and state governments
introduce new measures to renovate
public transportation systems including
new sanitation protocols as part of
these protocols all trains would be
sprayed with a high strength
disinfectant before they could be
certified for use in reality this
disinfectant would be the same poison
used to take down the first train Aid or
the foundation studied once any and all
potent threats had been rendered
harmless trains that were found to be
formally living would be converted into
fully functioning trains and allowed to
run as normal in order to avoid
unnecessary interruptions to the public
in addition to these containment
measures the foundation monitors all
social media for mentions of unusual
activity on trains or mentions of any
more missing persons lost at Metro
stations the original Los Angeles video
that started it all was scrubbed from
the internet entirely so by all means
take advantage of your local public
transportation options but remain
Vigilant and keep your wits about you
and remember next time you travel by
train if you see something say something
more specifically if you see something
unusual on a train if it looks a little
different than it did yesterday if its
sounds don't seem quite right make sure
to let everyone around you know that it
is not safe to be here and quickly make
your way to the exit then maybe walk to
your destination instead it might make
you a little bit late but hey better
wait than dinner now go check out
scp-342 a ticket to ride and scp-2086
man eating bus for more perilous
anomalies on public transport